welcome to this video I'm playing offer
offer from Israel had no played him
before it seems ok a king's indian we
get and it's not a good fart hmm I could
I could play maybe something else I ok I
wanted to play the protrusion system
after if I go d5 now this is impossible
this is I think the possible move try to
prevent you 5 or not trying I mean I
really prevent e5 for the time being
asking black how he's intending to set
up his his pieces ok hmm yeah maybe here
first and only after this further
provocation drop back he cannot play if
I've d 5 f-5 because of the captcha on
f5 takes gtx 95 as one moves haha
interesting so he's saying that he's
able to go to go to to f4 after 92 94
yeah that's true but I can go here so
that after f5 I have night h4 which
looks very problematic ok he avoided
that mmm 92 all night h4 maybe 92 it
both looks good attacking h5
and asking black about the future of the
bishop on age three i also have before
just kicking this night away this looks
problematic for black really what is his
move now yeah just dropping back I can I
can think about before and maybe after
before maybe you can take a form as
weird as it looks with f5 at the end
this could could be working now but okay
I don't believe it 94 94 94 94 Bishop g2
maybe
no what this is very silly am Bishop g2
yeah it's possible
ok so maybe maybe I can can trap this
bishop I don't know I mean this is a bit
frustrating because the whole black
opening was pretty much a joke with
night h5 and Knight f6 back and
everything but ok maybe this wasn't as
bad as it looked I mean it looked really
like like unplayable but ok let's see my
dears f3 trapping tried to trap the
bishop f3 Bishop g2g form yeah I don't
know if I can if I can really catch it
yeah g4 here there's always those things
like Knight g4 maybe that's very close
to to being possible
ok anyway what what else kh5 give this
check due to g3
Bishop 83 King g3 hgfg it really looks
like they're there is some tactic coming
but okay I need to try to get get this
deserve this bishop otherwise it it's
really not making any sense I don't see
a refutation yet
hmm I don't know what you should do is
this some tactic that you can try a
night h5 maybe but I can take the night
night at five takes you can least keep
the bishop but I don't really see how we
save that yeah this this may be getting
I need to walk all the way up here not
much not much I can do about it it's not
clear how bad it really is at least not
clear to me yeah but I have a I have an
active Queen now with Queenie six mate
Jang the threat now this is good no
really this is good for white I have
good control and Queen Queen to e6 yeah
that was lucky
and to maybe just get the night into
this 95 thing a Cairo could be one
activating and their c5 maybe right away
right away as good very close to being
good but okay he cannot really do much
my King Silas is very well and very well
organized I wonder about rook c8
possibly mc5 there is no direct winning
least I don't see it
okay maybe cover this for the moment
it's not ideal but ok so is some managed
to break through them but 96 a 9 p-5 I
mean with 96 now in the game looped
looks dangerous I'm threatening rugby
sevens rugby 17b 796 winning the Queen
now that's a good coordination now yeah
he is just ignoring that ok I don't see
any big truck can take on f2 or
something but this is just some checks
and maybe I can really trap this this is
this strange bishop on edge one but it
was not planned beforehand now before
was a very silly move Bishop g2 I should
simply prevent time morning get the
chicky as well check
checkmate yeah let's look at this yeah
in this this moment black black already
is in some trouble because he lost so
much time it's not we are not losing or
anything but it's a very comfortable
setup form for wide the question is what
is the the best best way to play it well
be for Bishop g2 is not the solution I
can also think about rook g1 orgy form
is also interesting group g1 is sung a
conservative move I just covering g2
something like this is quite nice now I
have the ideal piece set up and I have
before coming while it's not so clear
what blacks counter player looks like on
the on the Kings side job at let's check
if I can if I really could trap this
Bishop here what after this B form funny
computer actually gives Bishop g2 as a
mistake and says why it is clearly
better here but with King f1 here this
is this is much easier hmm we had had
not considered this at all and why
didn't I consider this move how'd the
same here mine's a king of Iron King f1
some German sleeping in their king of
one is really quite clearly superior I
will get the bishop without any any
problem stock fishes main line is this
then I five
3f for Bishop two and then the desperado
yeah this is a very nice position for
what especially because the long term
here this Bishop will get something to
do on the light squares this is very
nice okay so this was much better than
what i did with with f3 ng form this is
now the opposite and tough tough the
same yeah the computer wants to
sacrifice no one g4 yeah i had seen that
but i thought that this isn't check this
isn't the end of the world but Jim yeah
yeah here basically he just has a check
here that's not so terrible but very
difficult to evaluate the computer says
about equal minus 0.2 not very hard to
say okay thanks for watching